I don't want to totally move on from the
weird sex stuff I mean I do socially I
would like us to move on from the weird
sex stuff but we can't move on from it
in the news because it's everywhere it's
not just in the bowels of the Internet
it's not just Shady people with with
dodgy companies
it's in the government it's in the U.S
military the United States Navy has just
launched a new recruitment campaign that
guess they didn't they didn't pay any
attention to the lessons of Bud Light
they've launched a new recruitment
campaign the try is to get new sailors
by promoting drag
you can see there's this uh active duty
sailor
is a drag queen
he
he's not he's not exactly a transgender
he's
he's a full over the top drag queen 24
year old Joshua Kelly performs under the
alter ego Harpy Daniels
and video going around right now of some
of his performances that he's posted
while serving as a squadron's
administrative supervisor
Kelly's shows are part of lip sync
competitions
he's very very different there he is in
a dress
they're supposed to boost morale not
sure
this okay I've seen enough of the drag
queen sailor uh now
you would think this would not
necessarily boost morale among service
men however you know there have long
been sort of jokes
about the Navy and and I guess this is
really my problem with the new drag
recruitment tool is not that it's
decadent and debauched and
counterproductive my problem with the
new drag recruitment initiative from the
Navy is that it's just a waste of money
because the Navy already had very very
high quality recruitment materials in
this vein going back to the 1970s
silence
[Music]
and I love the Navy was really leading
the charge with that recruitment tool
because the Navy obviously was was the
front man for it but you had all the
branches of the military you had the
Cowboys you had the Indians you had the
construction workers you know I I assume
also the Army and the Marines in the Air
Force and the Coast Guard somewhere back
there
uh
look Navy if you want if you want to
double down on these kinds of things
that's uh that's fine and a lot of
people are going to joke and they're
going to use that apocryphal quote from
Winston Churchill which is that Naval
tradition is nothing but rum sodomy in
the Lash which is a funny quote even
though Churchill never said it but
notice the difference
back in the 70s back at every time in
history before now
the Navy had this kind of joke about it
which was that it attracted guys who
were a little bit light in the loafers
okay and that was that was the joke and
in those days the sailors would push
back on that joke
that was the joke and they say how dare
you that's not what we're like get out
of here shut up you're a jerk whatever
you know you'd push back
today
the Navy is totally embracing that and
they're using that as a recruitment tool
it's a it's a an inversion of society
the likes of which we're seeing in every
other sector of society now
when you want to
protect
your data from the prying eyes of these
weirdos upending our culture you're
going to want to check out expressvpn
right now go to expressvpn.com Knowles
when powerful interests want to push
their agenda who's just say they
couldn't get big Tech to silence any
voice that doesn't fit the narrative
Americans are being forced to give up
their ability to speak and I for one am
not going to let my voice be censored
that is why I choose expressvpn and you
should too the problem with big Tech is
not only do they attempt to censor you
they also track what you do online what
you're searching for the videos you
watch everything you click they can
match your activity to your true
identity using your device's unique IP
address when I use expressvpn they can't
see my IP address at all my identity is
anonymized by secure VPN server plus
expressvpn encrypts 100 of network
traffic for protection from hackers and
eavesdroppers expressvpn is so easy to
use you just fire up the app tap one
button to connect
not just me saying this Business Insider
The Verge many other Tech journals rate
expressvpn as the number one VPN in the
world protect your online data today by
using the only VPN that I trust go to
expressvpn.com Knowles get three extra
months for free
expresvpn.com Knowles expressvpn.com
Knowles to learn more
speaking of our very corrupt and
decadent establishment
this story has not gotten nearly enough
attention and it is delightful
Noam Chomsky is at this point I think
about a thousand years old he's a
celebrated linguist but more than he is
known for his linguistic scholarly work
he is known for being the preeminent
public intellectual on the left and he's
always sticking his nose in where it
doesn't belong and he's always
pontificating about all matters of
politics and economics
and he's a pretty interesting linguist
he's actually had somewhat interesting
things to say on politics and economics
but very very much a man of the left
and
some might say sanctimonious about his
politics
Well turns out
something we've learned from the trials
surrounding Jeffrey Epstein
it's that Noam Chomsky was buddies with
Jeffrey Epstein Wall Street Journal
discovered this and they reached out to
Professor Chomsky for comment
his response was
first response is that it is none of
your business
or anyone's
second is that I knew him and we met
occasionally
kind of a defensive response because a
lot of people knew Jeffrey Epstein
Jeffrey Epstein was clearly a political
operative he was very very wealthy he
invited lots of fancy people to all of
his parties so one could very easily say
oh yes I met him we were we were raising
money for MIT which is where Chomsky
teaches or we were raising money for
this cause or that cause and so yes we
had some dinners it's no big deal but he
doesn't say it he says yeah it's none of
your business yeah I know we met we met
sometimes
we know from the flight schedules
Epstein was scheduled to fly with
Chomsky and his wife to have dinner with
them as well as Woody Allen and his wife
not a great look if you're
if you're hanging out with a guy who is
known to have preyed on minors for sex
not great to simultaneously be hanging
out with a guy whose reputation is that
he has a sexual obsession with minors
was asking about this he goes if there
was a flight which I doubt it would have
been from Boston to New York 30 minutes
I'm unaware of the principle that
requires I inform you about an evening
spent with a great artist
now what's also weird is Chomsky hung
out with with Epstein after Epstein was
convicted of the child sex stuff so he
says what was known about Jeffrey
Epstein was that he had been convicted
of a crime and had served his sentence
according to U.S laws and Norms that
yields a clean State lots of other
Epstein Associates had an excuse this
Noam Chomsky one
this fails on every level
it was after the sex crime convictions
he's now trying to excuse the sex crime
convictions he's hanging out
with other odd characters
he apparently did it a lot of times
The Establishment is trying to sweep
this under the rug
and and we like to think
oh well it was just some people in high
positions of power
no it's it's all of it even Noam Chomsky
who has a reputation of being sort of
above it all he's a radical leftist the
liberal establishment doesn't like him
very much now they're all they're all
just kind of in it
together
I don't I'm not even that interested in
Gnome Chomsky in himself or the Jeffrey
Epstein story in itself I'm interested
in what it says about the whole power
structure in the U.S there aren't lots
of tiny little factions and oh the
Chomsky type people they don't like Joe
Biden and today you know and Biden he
doesn't like this fashion no the liberal
establishment
pretty solid
and even though they don't have
necessarily the majority of the country
in terms of the people who live here who
are citizens they've got a lot of the
power and they do a lot of dodgy stuff
and they don't think they need to answer
questions from anybody and they don't
have to pay any consequences
yeah I know tell me tell me what you're
thinking brilliant incisive handsome I
agree if you want to get more of it
you've got to ring that Bell ding dong
click the thing subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time
[Music]